Hi everyone. My name is Gabe de Mesa.
I'm an engineer here at OpenGov and
today we're going to be talking about
agents in production, specifically how
OpenGov built and scaled OG Assist. Uh
so
um
this presentation is going to be
jam-packed with just so much good stuff.
Uh we're going to talk about uh AI
agents. We're going to talk about our
harness. We're going to talk about um
evals, observability, traces. We're
going to talk about um
tools and skills. Um
It's There's going to be a lot of good
stuff in here. We're going to talk to
you guys about uh what we do at OpenGov
and how we operate at the scale that uh
we operate at um in production, so
you'll be able to see a real use case
and workload uh with AI agents. Um so
without further ado, let's get started.
Okay, agenda. So just really quickly
going to go through uh high-level what
we're going to talk about today. Uh I'm
going to tell you guys a little bit
about OG Assist and what uh OpenGov is.
I'm going to tell you guys the origin
story of how this all kind of came to
be. Uh we're going to talk about OG
Assist's uh big bet on effect.
Uh a little bit into our core agent
loop. Uh we're going to talk about the
A2A protocol, evals, and sandboxing.
We're going to talk about how we manage
long context. We're going to talk about
um
monitoring, observability, how we
collect feedback uh and how we iterate
on that feedback. We're going to lastly
uh also talk about tools and skills and
how at OpenGov uh we use um
AI not only externally uh that we uh
serve to customers, but also internally
to improve our development workflows.
Just a little bit about me before we go
any further. My name is Gabe. I'm a
software engineer here at OpenGov. I
work on the AI agents team and
I'm one of the folks that helped build
OG Assist and some of the systems that
you guys will be seeing today.
So, a little bit about OpenGov. OpenGov
is a software company
on a mission to power more effective and
accountable government. So, OpenGov
sells ERP software. That's things like
budgeting, procurement, asset
management, and permitting. And
we were founded about 14 years ago and
what's cool is
um
we have this thing called OG Assist and
OG Assist is this little button on the
top of all of our products in the in the
navigation bar. And what's cool is
all of our product suites and product
teams
have built tools and skills in order to
power this button. So, for example, if I
open up
this this
if I click this button and I open up OG
Assist, it says, "Hey, I'm going to ask
about rate codes, which is very specific
to utility billing, the current product
that I'm in." And you can see that
inside of this kind of chat interface,
I'm able to speak to an agent and the
agent is able to make tool calls in
order to
look up information against data inside
of that suite. So, it's really cool
to be able to kind of first-party create
these experiences through the capability
that we've built called OG Assist.
Okay, so just a
quick story about how this all came to
be. So,
a little while back we we we saw that AI
was really starting to take off and a
principal uh spun up this new team
called the AI agents team and asked me
to join. And um
instantly I said yes and OG Assist
started to to grow and we started to
integrate OG Assist into all our
products. And uh not only our back-end
capabilities, but also our front-end
capabilities as well. So, you'll see
that one of the capabilities that we
give the agent is it's able to
um see what's on the screen and and see
and and and take action on what's on the
page. So, you could see that uh I'm
asking the agent here, "Hey, hey, what's
on the screen? Can you maybe highlight
uh some of the next steps that I could
take?" So, you can see that the agent
here is thinking. It's saying, "Okay,
what tools do I have available to use?"
And "Hey, let me go and highlight
something that you could actually click
on and and tell you more about it." So,
just another capability of OG Assistant.
Just a little
short story about how this all came to
be.
So, the big bet on Effect. Um so, I
really wanted to include this slide
because um here on the Agents team, we
made a huge bet to
um
to to bet on Effect. And suffice to say
it's paid off in dividends.
Um we write Effect. So, Effect is this
library for TypeScript. It's open source
and it helps you write better um
TypeScript code.
Uh
you know, it's got a lot of uh stuff
baked in it like a
a schema similar to like Zod, if you've
ever used that. It's also got um things
for error handling, uh for logging, for
traces, for
uh it's just got so much in there. It
really helps write better code and
structure your code better and uh helps
with architecture, spinning up new
services for
uh and and for us on the Agents team,
really helping uh design and build the
the core agent loop. So, you'll see
throughout this presentation sprinkled
in um how Effect on our team uh has paid
off in dividends. So, we we really love
Effect here at OpenGov and we encourage
other folks to try it out and um
yeah, let's keep going.
The Effect Native Loop.
So, originally we were on LangGraph and
that was fine until the team really
started to scale uh and our use cases
started to evolve.
So, we
decided to move over to our own kind of
Effect Native Agent Loop to have full
regency over this
uh Agent Loop such that if we have
complex use cases or features that we
need to build, we could kind of
get in we we had full control of the of
the Agent Loop. And not only that, but
now we're fully on Effect. So, all the
cool things you get with Effect is now
propagated throughout the entire Agent
Loop, like the tracing, structured
concurrency, the logging, everything is
more fine-grained control, and it it
really allows us to really unlock the
full potential uh having our own Agent
Loop from the ground up. Um so, another
thing I wanted to mention is on the left
side, you'll see a code example. This is
really the basics of the Effect Loop
that we're using. Uh we're using this
thing called the Effect AI package, and
in that package, there's this thing
called um
there's a chat and a language model. So,
with the chat, you can instantiate like
an a chat, for example, and then you
could stream text using
um
that that kind of
stream text function, you could pass in
a prompt. And what's cool is uh with a
language model under the hood uh of
since we're kind of doing dependency
injection,
we could pass in a different language
model if we were to uh hot swap to
another one, for example. So, really
just having full control of our own
Agent Loop just kind of gives us all the
levers, and it really just unlocks the
full capabilities of the model, and uh
for the team as well, to have full
agency over this this loop.
Another thing I wanted to mention is the
agent-to-agent protocol. So, here on the
agents team we've had a lot of success
with this protocol. So, this protocol
being the protocol that Google created.
Um kind of an open protocol for agents
to intercommunicate, but um we found
this very useful for uh defining our
agent routes. So, for example, in the
back end and our model and our schema to
follow this kind of
agent protocol. So, we modeled So, for
example, there's this thing called an
agent card which you see here and it's
got the name of the agent, a
description, etc., right? And having
this kind of rigorous protocol, this
rigorous spec really helped drive our
development and drive alignment because,
you know, all we had to do was um align
with this spec and follow this spec and
we knew that this was kind of the
contract that our front end and back end
would both consume and and produce. So,
um this uh I would say also has been
uh very helpful for us. And And what's
really cool is A2A has a lot of
extensions, right? So, you could extend
the protocol uh add in like metadata. Uh
there's also A2UI.
Um so,
lots of fun stuff uh with A2A protocol,
but uh this is kind of what's worked for
us. So, just sharing that with with you
folks.
Feedback and evals.
So, here the quote is, "Shipping is the
start, not the finish." So, what we do
here uh on the agents team is we have
kind of multiple ways we do evals and
collect feedback. Um
Obviously, you know, we'll have folks
uh call in or or email us or just let us
know and tell us, but the main way is we
have this thumbs up and thumbs down
mechanism and here someone is able to
tell us, "Hey, this this worked really
well. This was a great response." Or,
"That wasn't a great response." And that
signal we take and we're able to iterate
on.
Uh, and we can take it back and help
improve, uh,
you know, the response in the future.
Um, we also have automated evals, so
in in the in our CI we we have evals
that run against real completions, so we
could test the prompt against, "Hey, did
it hit some tools? Did it do what it's
supposed to do?" And that also helps
with our accuracy. So, uh, those
automated evals in conjunction with
collecting feedback really help us, um,
improve our
uh, our our tools, our skills,
um, our harness and and that's really
how how we're able to iterate so fast
and so quickly.
Humans in the loop. So, this is a really
cool feature we built where we
deterministically interrupt the agent
loop if there is a tool call approval
required. So, if an agent tries to make
a tool call that it needs human approval
for, it'll show this UI and the human
uh, can click accept or reject. So,
explicitly rejecting or explicitly
accepting, uh, the action that the agent
is trying to make. And this ensures
that, uh, you know, we're building trust
and also ensuring that, uh, you know,
we're being safe, especially when the
agent's trying to do a mutating
operation and always always always
making sure that, um, humans are in the
driver's seat.
Sandboxing. So, another thing that we,
uh, worked on, um, kind of similar to
the safety slide we just saw was, um,
whenever an agent tries to execute code
or tries to create files, it does so in
a sandbox. So, we gave our agents
sandboxes such that it could spin up
these sandboxes on demand and it could
use those sandboxes to honestly write
code, execute code, create files and
it's kind of this safe ephemeral
isolated space such that the agent can
can can take action in there and not and
we don't have to worry about uh any risk
to you know our our production systems.
Um and it's it's really cool cuz they
also get uh tied uh tear down at the end
so um
in this example I said, "Hey, create a
PDF uh for the folks of the AI Engineer
Conference 2026." And um allow me to
download it so I could share it with
them. And you could see that the agent
created this really cool PDF inside of
that sandbox. So just really wanted to
cover the sandbox feature and just give
you a brief kind of overview of of
sandboxing.
Long context. So
um
inside of Ogie Assist, we have hit many
hurdles like with especially with legacy
models now like with uh token limits or
just way too much just completely
overloaded with context especially as
conversations get longer. So we found
that
having some sort of
um rolling summarization was more
effective than you know always stuffing
in the latest and most recent uh
messages
uh
rather just you know give like a running
summary after n number of messages and
uh maybe you only want the like n minus
five most recent messages or n minus 10
most recent messages, right? Um and it
may be that you're only talking about a
specific topic now, but you may want to
refer to
uh context earlier like a hundred
messages above, then
um
it uh that's where kind of the the
memory component comes in cuz when you
have this rolling summary of a a really
long conversation, then you could do
recall over that uh summarization. And
um you know, if you ask the agent, "Hey,
remember that thing that we talked
about?" then the agent within the thread
will be like, "Yeah, I do know what you
were talking about. I have kind of this
short little tidbit." And it can, you
know, follow up and and and do more kind
of with that uh
summary rolling summary in mind. So,
that's kind of how we handled long
context and memory, and it's worked
pretty well for us. So, uh just wanted
to share a little bit about that and how
we've uh solved the long context
problem.
UI on the fly. So, um in this example, I
said to the agent, "Hey,
generate me a long essay, but give me
some examples about what the essay could
be about." So, what's really cool is the
agent had this primitive registered uh
uh this form, and it was able to build
out this form for me at runtime and give
me some options of what I could choose
from. So, it feels very personal and it
feels very kind of in the moment that
it's able to to give me these options
just at runtime. So,
um
this is kind of just a short little
thing I wanted to include here about
generative UI and how we
uh are able to render UIs on the fly.
You can't scale what you can't see. So,
um
this uh
this kind of section is about tracing uh
and observability. Really, what's cool
about Effect is you kind of get tracing
out of the box. Um you know, when you
use these effect functions, they all get
kind of tagged automatically with like
these spans, and kind of the span gets
picked up and feeds into these traces so
that you can kind of get these kind of
drill downs of these function calls. So,
here's an example of a trace from the
effect team. I have it linked. You could
see that like, "Hey, when you hit this
API, go to this endpoint, to this
handler." And you know, etc. And it
takes And what what's really cool is you
could profile all your traces, right?
So, this takes a total of this many
seconds and you can see where the
bottleneck is here. If there's a
failure, you can cross-reference data
across services. So, really, really
important, especially working in agentic
systems where we're we're integrating
with other teams and other APIs and
other um
other platform capabilities. So,
what's cool with effect is you get all
this tracing out of the box and it
really makes building this agentic
experience, debugging it, and
maintaining it just a breeze.
Tools and skills. So,
uh not only did we make a big bet on
effect, but we also made a big bet on
tools and skills. So, we believe that
tools and skills are really all you
need.
And in this case, you could see on the
left, we have this tool called get dad
joke. And this is kind of the effect way
and kind of the building blocks of how
we do things here at OpenGov, but
you know, this is pulled from the effect
website, but you could see, "Hey, this
is how you make a tool." And then you
add it to a tool kit, which is a
collection of tools, and then you can
register this this tool kit with the
with the language model. So, for
example, if you had a prompt that said,
"Hey, generate some dad jokes about
pirates." Well, guess what? The agent
has a tool uh that can help get
a dad joke. So,
um
really, this is the the building blocks
of how we did tools
and eventually skills and
really just is has paid off wonderfully
for for our organization. So,
um really recommend trying out this
effect AI package from
uh effect and um just trying out
building out your own tools and skills.
Developer velocity. So, not only do we
build agents for our customers, but we
also use agents um here internally uh in
OpenGov. So, we uh use a lot of Claude
and Cursor uh and it's just really been
a game-changer for our team.
Um it's funny because we're building
tools and skills for customer-facing uh
agents and and that has been great, but
we're also building them internally as
well to help accelerate our development
workflows. So, things like Claude,
Cursor, Claude agents, they really help
accelerate how we read, write, review
code and and ship. Um so, it's it's just
been such an accelerate. So, definitely
just wanted to mention that uh before we
wrap up.
That's it. Thanks so much for watching.
You've made it to the end. Let's build
agents that ship to production.